Now, I've never interrupted a wedding per se.
But if I was going to, this is how I would do it.
This is called "Speak Now".
I think in writing this album by myself, there was absolutely nothing holding me back.
Just the idea of, "if I'm going to write this album by myself" say it all.
I think that, you know, co-writers are such a huge, amazing part of the music industry...
...and I've loved working with them. And I've written songs, all kinds in different ways, but...
...with this album, writing it by myself,...
...I think I was more inclined to say the things...
...that I may not have been courageous enough to bring up in a co-writing session.
I wrote probably in total, about 40 to 50 songs for this record and...
...chose between them,...
...kind of very ruthlessly just said, "May the best song win"...
..."and may this song that says it in its truest form win."
When you've already done this kind of song before and,...
...you know, you don't wanna repeat yourself,...
...you wanna take musical risks,...
...but you never wanna alienate people.
There are a lot of fine lines that you have to balance.
All the while, never saying the same but never changing.
It's this whole, complicated thing. I feel like this album feels right.
And finally arriving on that, after two years of working for it, is really cool.